what exactly happens in the fantasy
suite is it like is it like this is it
more like this yep
that actually happened tonight's episode
of after the final rose was jam-packed
with cringe-worthy and confusing moments
first up Chris Harrison's non-stop
wedding talk man remember last week when
you told me you were ready to marry this
woman right here right now she just said
a set a wedding date now we can't wait
to hear about that wedding day then the
continuous awkward cuts to Ben's pastor
why was he standing there the whole time
we all knew there wasn't going to be a
wedding get the poor guy a chair your
pastor Danny Wilson for more sign Deanna
yeah he's here but there was a second
proposal then even asked for the Neil
Lane sparkler back that he gave the
25-year old flight attendant can I
borrow this for a second will you marry
me once again and Jimmy Kimmel made it
super awkward interrupting Lauren's
wedding talk to ask about the fantasy
suites show me on the dolls where you
touched each other and last but not
least Jojo was announced the new
bachelorette while sitting next to her
ex-boyfriend please welcome our new
bachelorette Jojo